what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with devil's reign now picking
up from the end of last week's video
right the last issue this basically
takes place two weeks after the attempt
of what you could kind of call the
secret avengers i guess they don't
officially have a name they're just
calling themselves the avengers but
basically their attempt on wilson fisk
if anything to take the life of wilson
fisk right to take him down of course
they proved to be unsuccessful but what
this did is it basically emboldened with
wilson fisk right in the sense that now
they've got drones out there that are
basically always on the hunt for these
differing members of the avengers as
well as anybody who either has
information or anybody who may have some
kind of powers out there the other part
of this is that wilson fisk has heavily
fortified the entirety of the the
mayoral office right where he resides so
now it's one of these things where in a
lot of ways because of the actions of
the superheroes they've almost kind of
pushed the city of new york into
becoming a like a militarized zone right
it's kind of crazy but regardless of
course you end up having wilson fisk
who's met by the arrival of doctor
octopus right who has of course this
other octopus henchmen and so on and so
forth and it's one of those funny things
because in the end wilson fisk kind of
asks him like you have what's basically
a hulk and like a wolverine and a ghost
rider and yourself why don't you just
come take the throne of mayor for me and
the response of otto is just basically
saying like because it means nothing to
me right like why would i go through all
that time and all that energy and all
that effort to kill you in order to
become mayor but i've got like much
bigger things that i'm focusing on
besides that and it's kind of this funny
thing right because he says like you've
always been obsessed with power wilson
fisk right and i'm i'm happy to have you
basically sit in a useless seat to shake
hands and kiss babies he's like but i am
working on making the world a better
place right i'm working on much bigger
things the technology in the baxter
building following reed richard's arrest
has linda basically given me like
marvelous technologies that i can use
for my own ends right that made all
these octobots possible and all that
kind of stuff at the end of the day
you're focusing on small stuff as you
always do because you're a small-minded
person i'm focusing on big things he
says also something that you should be
aware of he's like in the end we have
basically continued to deliver and we
want to deliver this news that like
crime is again down in the city of new
york which means we've arrested your son
butch and then basically leaves now
following that matt murdock of course
goes to basically visit uh foggy nelson
remember because foggy nelson is
basically the lawyer for luke cage and
luke cage announced his candidacy for
mayor of the city of new york to run
against wilson fisk because from the
avengers perspective it's the only real
way to get fisk out of his position that
if they were to successfully assassinate
him he would basically become a martyr
and he would prove them right right he
would prove himself right and saying
that avengers or superheroes are just
too dangerous because it's literally
superheroes assassinated a political
official
right that's not something to be done
lightly of course foggy nelson was
basically beat up by henchmen of wilson
fisk in order to basically send a
message now the funny thing about this
is that foggy nelson as you know those
are guys who are familiar with daredevil
foggy mel's [ __ ] doesn't take lip off
anybody and so it's one of those things
where it's like okay i mean yeah i get
what they were trying to do but like
they're gonna have to try harder than
that this whole catholic guilt that you
have you know matt murdock of well you
know foggy i never should have involved
you and i put you in harm's way stuff it
right and even he's just like i absolve
you my son now get out of here right
like go do your thing
it's one of the things i always loved
about foggy nelson right but in the
midst of that of course as matt murdock
is leaving he's met by the arrival of
his twin brother mike murdock now as a
bit of a refresher here for those of you
guys who are unfamiliar with mike
murdock we did discuss them before so we
won't go super in-depth here that
basically there was a point where matt
murdock had brought together a team of
inhumans to essentially find a way or at
least brought together a team of people
which included in humans to find a way
to defeat wilson fisk one of those was a
person named reader who could basically
manifest anything he read and that in
researching matt murdock and seeing the
identity of mike murdock this led to him
accidentally creating mike murdock now
the reason why we've never really talked
about him before the reason we never
really addressed him before is because
in all honesty marvel will probably get
rid of him pretty soon especially when
you get around to the point where like
the the netflix daredevil series starts
to launch marvel's probably going to
kill off
mike murdock right so you know we can do
a video on him if you guys are
particularly interested but right now
there's just not really a reason to i
don't see him lasting much longer in
marvel comics uh and so it's just one of
those things where where you kind of
switch over to wilson fisk himself and
because of what's going on here one of
the things you remember in the last
video that we discussed or that we did
that you have the purple man zebedee
kilgrave right a person who has the
ability to emit pheromones they can
basically make people do whatever it is
that he wants them to do so long as
their will power isn't too high or they
don't have any kind of like telepathic
protection or anything along those lines
but there was also the purple man's
children and that his children are the
other half of this puzzle the powers of
the purple man only go so far but if
wilson fisk has the powers of his kids
and the powers of purple man then he
would be nigh unstoppable and he kind of
has his sights set on the office of the
presidency now remember the entire
motivation for why wilson fisk is doing
this is because somewhere along the line
basically matt murdock had done
something to make him forget daredevil's
identity it's a personal grudge the the
reality of this and like the equivalent
of what's going on here is if like
you're your worst enemy in the world
came to you and basically said that they
they were able to successfully do
something to like defeat you in some
capacity and you had no real recourse
that's what this is the equivalent of
right it's basically kingpin essentially
boxing matt murdock in saying okay fine
if you are going to strip me of the
knowledge of your identity against my
will right you're going to screw with my
head then that's fine i will screw with
your life and not just your life the
lives of everybody around you this is
really nothing more than a personal
grudge that's something to understand
here right this is not wilson fisk
genuinely doing the good thing and
believing he can actually make the world
better no everything he's doing here
harnessing the power of the purple man
setting his sights on the office of the
presidency it's all to basically get
back to matt murdock is really all it is
right and so basically he ends up
bringing together the thunderbolts so
you got like john walker you've got
rhino right you've got the new electro
all that kind of stuff and it's one of
these things something to keep in mind
the thunderbolts are really more
anti-heroes than they are straight-up
villains they're basically you know
people who were at some point in line uh
maybe good guys kind of not good guys
and have a questionable past well i
guess when i say that i'm really more
referencing john walker these guys have
always okay they've always kind of been
bad guys i mean two would agree with
john walker he's a little more anti-hero
right he you know the the commission on
superhuman activities basically replaced
captain america with him and then he
lost his phone and that led to him just
like you know basically being stripped
of his powers in the mantle of captain
america going back to steve rogers but
again it's one of those things where
like what wilson fisk is asking them to
do here is to basically find the purple
children and that's where the the
villains really kind of draw the line
it's one of the things about marvel's
villains right very rarely do you ever
find a marvel villain who will do
whatever they need to do right who will
do anything and everything they have a
few of them like taskmaster is a good
example right you pay taskmaster to kill
a person he will kill them it doesn't
really matter who they are right like he
will kill that person frank castle to a
degree but only when it comes to
villains right marvel really kind of
shies away from this idea that like
villains will kill kids they really sort
of they don't they don't really deal
with that all too often and rightfully
so and so it's one of these things where
literally john walker's like i mean look
you know i need to know what these kids
did right i mean why are we going after
them and so what he ends up doing or at
least what kingpin does is he invokes
the power of the purple man and says
like you will do what i tell you to do
mr walker and then of course with
walker's willpower really kind of being
being lower than it needs to be to
withstand the powers of the purple man
ends up going alongside that instead and
so of course again following that you
basically pick up with who is in effect
the wife of wilson fisk at this point in
time typhoid mary of course we'll talk
about her here in a little bit what you
actually end up doing is switching over
to the prison where all the various
superheroes are being held where
essentially susan storm using her powers
to make herself invisible uh having
picked the the lock on her collar right
because she had an inhibitor collar but
she ended up taking a paper clip when
she was meeting with her attorney and
now has used that to free herself and
then in turn steals like one of the
passes off one of the guards they walk
by and then freeze reed richards and
then basically freezes you know opens up
all the other cells which allows all the
heroes to escape here's the thing about
this right on the surface you could look
at that and call this a plot device it's
actually not so susan storm is
ridiculously capable right i mean one of
the things to understand here you're
talking about a woman whose power to
create force fields can withstand the
power of celestials so it's no small
thing so it's not beyond the realm of
possibility to believe that she could
basically use a paper clip to pick a
lock on her inhibitor collar what this
is also designed to do is illustrate the
idiocy of just your average person in
comparison to the fantastic four and the
reason why i say that is if you go back
and you look at the events of civil war
when the idea of creating a prison for
those who wouldn't follow superhuman
registration was created or developed by
like reid and tony and hank pym really
read more than anybody else that reid's
first thought was we're gonna be
arresting some pretty heavy hitters
whether they have super strength or they
have intangibility or anything like that
so it's not enough to put them in a
prison we have to put that prison in a
place that they can't escape from and
that's why prison 42 during civil war
was located in the negative zone so that
even if they somehow did manage to
escape the prison where they gonna go
that's one of the things you kind of run
into here is that in this instance
literally they locked up all these
superheroes and they just put them in a
prison in the water and like that was it
right it just it's kind of like okay in
the end like a prison break is going to
happen especially when like two of the
people you have locked up right like
reed richards and tony stark are two of
the absolute smartest people in the
entirety of the marvel universe and so
again great big huge fight breaks out
and basically they end up you know
seemingly being able to overtake the
prison guards and start engineering
their own escape now one of the things
that goes on here and it's kind of
intriguing is that you do have like the
champions right so you've got like iron
heart and you've got uh kamala khan miss
marvel and you got like viv right like
vision's daughter which honestly i feel
like we should get caught up on the
champions i haven't read them in so long
but their comics were just fun right it
was like marvel's teen titans but better
it was it was just great
i just loved it right there's a great
big huge fight even with miles right
there's a great big huge fight where
like they're all involved in a conflict
with rhino and it's one of those things
where like rhino basically is like he's
here and he was like look like put on
put on these like basically put on these
discs right like put on these on these
things um and ultimately when that
happens the the bots themselves or the
drones are basically designed in such a
way to where they don't attack anybody
with a thunderbolt badge and when the
question is asked rhino why are you
giving us thunderbolt badges so these
thrones these drones won't attack us the
response of rhino is look like i know
i'm a bad guy right like i have not done
very good things over the course of my
life i've basically just been a horrible
human being anytime you ever saw me i
was committing some kind of a crime but
what wilson fisk is asking us to do to
find some kids and to bring those kids
in who seemingly haven't done anything
wrong not even i can can follow those
orders right not even i can abide that
right it's just that's a line that i
just want crush it's cool it's it's a
it's a great little thing i mean is this
like a rhino redemption arc no it's just
basically designed to illustrate that
the kinds of things that wilson fisk is
asking people to do are things that not
even villains are willing to do more so
than that it's showing there's trouble
in paradise right the foundations by
which wilson fisk is building his empire
were never stable to begin with and now
that instability is showing in the fact
that it's starting to crack so it's
really really awesome to see what you
also end up getting in the aftermath of
this is that miles basically ends up
racing off to the rest of the avengers
and then telling them like kingpin is
after the purple children right he's
after the kids of the purple man and
that while i was told by rhino and sure
i guess rhino is not necessarily the
most credible force the guy saved our
life but he could he could kill us all
with the greatest of ease if he chose to
but he saved us and so if this is true
and wilson fisk is going after the
purple children having them under his
control being able to use their powers
he'll dominate the world while he'll be
able to take everything over and so it's
one of those crazy things because what
you end up getting here is this is this
is the just a crazy moment you switch
over to wilson fisk and wilson fisk of
course always having the staff next to
him which basically allows him to
channel the powers of the purple man is
met by typhoid mary now typhoid mary
she's been around in daredevil comics
for a long long time she's had some
great story arcs and she's had some
awful story archer she's like every
comic book character ever she's never
had like 100 great arcs 100 of the time
that never happens but typhoid mary is a
person who basically has multiple
personality disorder right she's got
multiple personalities in her head some
of which have access to her powers and
others don't and her powers change
depending on which personality is taken
over right so like telepathy or
telekinesis or the ability to manipulate
fire imagine legion but with far fewer
personalities in his head and a far more
limited uh breadth of power at his
disposal and that's basically typhoid
mary right she's a mutant essentially
and so because of this though the the
interest between the two and what's kind
of intriguing is that one of the things
kingpin says is he kind of asked the
question like why can't i stop doing
this right why hold on to these things
that cause me nothing but pain my hatred
my position i'm so consumed by power and
revenge but i have you i think our fiery
beginning and how it gave way to
something more powerful more beautiful i
think back on the first time we made
love after battle and now i find i no
longer need that battle to find that
level of satisfaction and so so in the
end typhoid says like i feel the same
thing like i feel the same way she says
even though i don't even really remember
our first time years of treatments and
trauma have robbed me of so much but i
hold on to the feeling of when we were
first together and so wilson fisk in
turn says i wish we both had those
memories it doesn't feel fair i wish you
could remember and he invokes the power
of the purple man when he does and
typhoid mary remembers everything she
remembers everything about her own past
now she doesn't run from wilson fisk
right she doesn't like leave him right
it's just like she recalls everything
she's like oh my god what a gift and so
this is this is a whole change to the
power of the purple man remember the
power of jebediah kilgrave has only ever
been used historically in mobile comics
to dominate the wills of others but
here's something to understand here's
something to keep in mind here we only
ever saw his powers used that way
because he only ever used them that way
it wasn't as though zebedee kilgray was
a guy who was trying to find a way to
make the world a better place and he
just simply couldn't do it because his
powers wouldn't let him the guy's always
been a dick right like zebedee kilgrave
has always just been a horrible human
being who uses powers for like personal
gratification and for the betterment of
himself based on his own selfish desires
we've never seen an instance when
anybody ever used the powers of the
purple man to basically get other people
to remember and it kind of makes sense
right if the purple man's powers even if
they're only by pheromone can be used to
make people do things and even make
people believe things then it would
stand to reason the powers of the purple
man can be used to make people remember
things and so in the in in basically
understanding that right and coming to
that realization fist says like i need
air right i need space the weight of
years is crushing me the weight of hate
that i so desperately need to let go of
and he says he literally holds this
thing in his hand and says remember and
this is when he recalls the identity of
matt murdock as daredevil the question
you really have to ask here is what else
is wilson fisk remembering because he is
beset on all sides by deception and
trickery and lies so what's going to
happen when he recalls everything that's
actually the truth and realizes how much
he's been lied to i gotta tell you guys
this story just gets better and better
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace
you